I don't know I feel like I really want
Bigfoot to be real
do you know why I don't want Bigfoot to
be real because that's scary no
because you don't want to give all the
dudes a satisfaction who've been chasing
Bigfoots for 40 years that's exactly
why did I know you were gonna can I tell
you something if there's one group I
don't want to hear a [__] I Told You
So from it's those [__] people the
Bigfoot people
if you got a bunch of big because yeah
you by the way everybody you know what
I'm talking about
you don't want the Bigfoot people
walking around thinking they're the
smartest group in the world that's a
[__] real slippery slope do you know
what I mean